cargado por sus hermanos de armas el
cuerpo del cabo mayor máxime blanco
entró a los inválidos
un solemne homenaje nacional al soldado
de 34 años asesinado en mali el viernes
pasado blasco fue condecorado a título
póstumo por su valentía en el campo de
batalla
en nombre de la república francesa lo
hacemos oficial de la legión de honor
en 2019 durante un intenso tiroteo salvo
a dos de sus compañeros luego de que su
helicóptero se estrellara durante una
operación contrainsurgente
al sepultar su cuerpo el presidente de
manuel mccrone saludó a su familia
blasco deja un hijo de ocho años y a su
compañera quien ahora espera que el
presidente les conceda un matrimonio
póstumo muy físico cuando le dije a mi
hijo lo que quería lloró de alegría y se
puso muy contento me dije que esto es
importante y que es la manera de
reconstruir nuestras vidas para los
padres el dolor de perder a su hijo fue
demasiado para soportarlo pero ahora
quieren conocer a quienes lo acompañaron
en su última misión en su trabajo quiero
conocerlos porque realmente lo necesito
realmente para hablar de su hijo
y señalizó si sobre sus últimos días
como era lo necesito para tener un
cierre con forster
máxime blasco es el soldado número 52 en
ser asesinado en la región de sahel
desde 2013
[Música]